[Music]
final preparations underway for the
Consumer Electronics Show scheduled to
start in just two days the biggest Tech
Convention in the world many
International participants coming to
town for it but some have pulled out
because of recent covet testing
requirements from the CDC Victoria Saha
joins us live near the convention center
with the details Victoria
into Las Vegas but this week Travelers
coming in from several parts of Asia are
going to be required to submit a
negative covid test and now CES is also
implementing similar rules which may
impact the turnout
it's the biggest Tech show in the world
drawing in nearly hundreds of thousands
of people that traffic gets spread
throughout the valley especially for
Chinatown when people come in town they
always get this package deal with travel
agencies that they will take them to
different restaurants locally in town
and to different spots with many CES
attendees coming from different parts of
Asia they look for a little taste of
home when in Las Vegas pack people in
and out and traffic really really bad
John Chow is the owner of noodle pot in
the Chinatown Plaza he says the revenue
coming in from CES attendees makes up at
least 15 percent of his yearly income
sometimes four or five o'clock in the
morning
because we sold out during the days but
starting January 5th the U.S will
require all travelers from China Hong
Kong and Macau to provide a negative
covet test when entering the country
following this rule CES says from
January 1st to the 4th they will also
require anyone from these countries
attending to take a covet test according
to the Asian American Pacific Islanders
Chamber of Commerce that's having people
coming in cancel their travel plans I
don't really think it's very ideal for
the local businesses as last year's
attendance was around 40 000 people many
were hopeful 2023 would be a major
comeback year this is going to drop
I spoke with the convention and visitors
Authority they say CES is still
expecting around 100 000 people but CES
tells me that they won't know the final
numbers until after the convention is
over Victoria eight news now thank you
Victoria nces does start Thursday keep
that in mind if you're driving around
there and it runs until the 8th